so are there people in this world you
trusted or you still
trust I you know the the problem
is eventually I
cooperate
and at the time I didn't want to
cooperate I didn't believe in
cooperation but after seeing how many
people cooperate and the way the system
is set up I think that my understanding
of
loyalty is vastly more realistic now and
I think that if you're committing crime
if if you're absolutely like the things
I did I did a bunch of scumbag things
you know I mean I'm not killing people
but I'm doing scumbag things I'm lying
cheating stealing that I'm a thief you
know you boil down to it that's what I
am so you can't go around behaving like
a scumbag dealing with scumbags and then
expect those same scumbags to
suddenly abide by some kind of a street
code and not roll over on you you know
and it does happen but it's it's like in
the it's in the 90 percentile of people
that cooperate 90s something percent and
people cooperate when they're not even
looking at any real
time so if you're looking at 30 years
and and especially after going to prison
you go to prison and it's like this
guy's a standup guy over here he got 30
years he could have cooperated against
all of his codefendants but he
didn't nobody comes to see him his wife
divorced him you know his kids ended up
in foster care his you know his his
friends are are are cleaning out his
house nobody puts money on his on his
his books nobody comes to see him nobody
answers his phone nothing he took 30
years years most of those guys turned
around they end up getting indicted for
other things years later they
cooperate and the best thing this guy's
got going for him is that he can walk
around and say well he's a stand-up guy
that guy's going to the same halfway
house as me he's probably he's going to
do 30 years where I'm going to do 10 a
standup guy meaning he never snitched
right and so everybody's seeing
this example and saying well I'm going
to snitch then but it it sounds like
what people are doing is they're uh
signaling virtue signaling like there
are they would never snitch and actually
do secretly I mean what is it I I
remember I talked to one of the cosos at
the prison one time and he said
uh he said I said I said 50% of the
guys here snitched he goes there more
than that he said but listen he was 100%
of them are lying about it he said so do
you he there's nobody here that's going
to tell you they they snitched nobody so
there's guys tons of tons of them that
cooperate if 80 90% of of um defendants
cooperate you know you start doing the
math and you if you you ask 10 guys in
prison all of them say I didn't I didn't
cooperate I didn't cooperate I didn't
cooperate like okay you ask a 100 I
didn't cooperate nobody's going to say I
cooperated does that break your heart a
little
bit that people backstab each other like
this it it does it does
but you know I have such a low opinion
of people you know what I'm saying like
I don't expect it's not that I I don't
like people that I just don't expect
anything of them you know I don't expect
you to look out for me you know there
was a time when I did I thought I look
out for you you should look out for me
but I just don't expect that anymore see
but I think
Humanity flourishes because there is a
lot of people out there that do the
thing that is difficult to do in terms
of Integrity that may be but these these
aren't people with Integrity these are
criminals
if these were decent human beings and
all of them will tell you well why'd you
do that oh you know I was a drug addict
or I I needed the money well if you were
if you were a decent human being you
would have gotten off the drugs you
would have gone and gotten three jobs
you can work 80 hours a week I've done
it you can work 84 85 80 you can work 90
hours a week you can do that oh I did it
for my kids no you're lazy you could
have worked three jobs for your kids
instead you decided to sell
methampetamine well I was I was addicted
you would have gotten off me it wasn't
important it was the easy way out you're
not someone with Integrity so for you to
sit there and say hey I'm going to act
like a scumbag but now I got caught or
you got caught and I don't want you to
tell on me well you're a guy that robs
Banks you stick guns in people's faces
you kidnap people you torture people you
sell drugs you're not you're not a moral
ethical person but you want you want
everybody else to hold up to some
ethical code while while you're robbing
grandma
that's not right like you know so you
know I I get I get the whole omara code
you know and there was a mo there was a
time when I was you know delusional
enough to believe
that
but you know after you go after going
through it no and after going through it
multiple times
no
that